am 4 September 2022 demonstrierten mehr
als 70.000 Menschen in Prag für Russland
ja ihr habt richtig gehört diese 70.000
Menschen forderten dass ihr Land
Russland in gegen kommen und die
Sanktionen gegen Russland aufgeben Säule
und im Gegenzug wieder billiges Erdgas
zu erhalten Denkmal darüber nach die
Tschechen wurden jahrzehntelang von den
Russen gegängig ungeknechtet sie wissen
was ist heißt eine defacto Kolonie
Russland zu sein wenn so etwas also
schon in Tschechien passiert dann stellt
euch die Situation in anderen
europäischen Ländern vor die keine
russische Besatzung erlebt haben oder
nur zum Teil wie Deutschland
Mehrheit der Deutschen überzeugt
Sanktionen Schaden Deutschland mehr als
Russland auch in Frankreich und
Österreich gab es ähnliche Proteste aber
warum wollen so viele Menschen Russland
nachgeben nur die Antwort ist einfach es
ist Angst pure Angst
EU beschließt sechste sanktions Paket
gegen Russland das heutige Paket enthält
ein vollständiges eine vorverbot für
alle russischen Produkte auf dem Seeweg
die steckt 90% unserer derzeitigen Öl
Importe aus Russland ab denn Europa
schien in diesem Herbst auch ein wahres
Gas Armageddon zuzusteuern das
Schreckenszenario lautete Putin dreht
uns den Gashahn zu Energie wird
unbezahlbar es kommt zu Blackout die
Heizkörper bleiben eiskalt und die
Industrie steht still und nun droht auch
noch die nächste Energiekrise durch
Sanktion gegen Russland diesmal bei Öl
Benzin und Diesel ganz genau dieses
Paket ist am 5 dezember 2022 in Kraft
getreten aber keine Panik vielleicht
erinnert euch ja wir haben vor ein paar
Wochen hier auf visualpolitik ein Video
veröffentlicht indem wir über die
erdgaskrise gesprochen haben und die
Europa sie meistern kann heute wollen
wir daher nicht nur eine Zwischenbilanz
ziehen zum Thema Gas sondern euch auch
erklären wie Europa die Probleme bei der
Öl und Treibstoffversorgung in den Griff
bekommen die ölpokalypse verhindern
möchte lasst uns doch noch mal die
Eckpunkte der kapitulieren
am 1 September gab Russland bekannt das
ist den gesamten Gasfluss durch die Nord
Stream 1 abschalten werde Deutschland
bekäme dann direkt nicht mehr 20 oder
wenigstens 10% der früheren Mengen
sondern nichts niente ja da nicht doch
am 26 September kam es dann in der
Ostsee zu den bis heute nicht
vollständig aufgeklärten Explosionen an
beiden Nord streamleitungen es stimmt
zwar das immer noch etwas russisches Gas
durch die Ukraine und die Türkei kommt
aber wir reden hier von viel geringeren
Liefermengen tatsache ist das Moskau
seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine
die Gaslieferung nach Europa
schrittweise reduziert hat und
politischen Druck auszuüben
setzt Energie als Waffe ein indem er das
Angebot reduziert und unsere
Energiemärkte manipuliert er wird
scheitern Europa wird sich durchsetzen
ursula von der leiden die EU hatte
ihrerseit beschlossen auf russische
Kohle und teilweise russisches Gas zu
verzichten beim schwersten Erdgas jedoch
lange gezögert mit anderen Worten eine
gasrationierung in Europa schien fast
unvermeidlich und eine Rezession auch um
es klar zu sagen wir befinden uns in
einem energiekrieg mit Russland Putin
kann zwar nicht alle Westeuropäer in
sibirische Gulasch schicken allerdings
dachte er er könnte dafür allen ein
bisschen sibirische Kälte nach Hause
schicken tja aber bisher klappt das
nicht so recht und warum ihm das nicht
nur dank des warmen Herbst ist mit
Schwimmbad Temperaturen im Oktober
gelangt das werden wir euch heute
erklären aber eines nach dem anderen das
Problem betrifft ja auch die
Stromerzeugung wir alle sehen ja wie die
Stromrechnungen in die Höhe schießen
manche von uns zahlen das Vielfache von
dem was sie vorher bezahlt haben deshalb
war und ist die Panik groß Panik vor dem
vielleicht kältesten und teuersten
Winter unseres Lebens droht uns das
gasma gadon
und während uns all dies geschieht
scheint Russland auch noch den
Auswirkungen der Sanktionen und der
Lieferstopps zu widerstehen ich meine
der krimit tut wirklich alles dafür
damit es so aussieht etwa in den Putin
in Moskau das größte Riesenrad Europas
einweiht oder pompös den Anschluss von
vier ukrainischen Gebieten an die
Russische Föderation feiert Putin Post
immer wieder damit dass Russland nichts
verloren hat und auch nichts verlieren
wird
[Musik]
und wer wirklich mal das Pech haben
sollte seinen Sohn an der Front zu
verlieren bekommt halt einen Satz
frische bunte Handtücher vom Staat leben
die Gott in Russland leben aber die
Versuchung für viele Europäer ist groß
was wenn wir aufgeben und diese Option
kommt sicherheitspolitisch natürlich
nicht in Frage wenn Europa vor Putin
kapituliert würde ihn nichts mehr davon
abhalten den andere Länder einzufallen
aber nicht nur das was wäre wenn ich
euch sagen würde dass der zu zahlende
Preis gar nicht mal so hoch für uns ist
um es anders zu formulieren haben wir
ein Problem ja aber dieses ist viele
kleine als jenes Gas und dass ich viele
Leute ausmalen seht euch zum Beispiel
diese Grafik egal
[Musik]
was ihr hier seht sind die
niederländischen ttf-gastuters das ist
der Maßstab für den Gaspreis in Europa
wie ihr seht erreichte der Gaspreis ein
Höhepunkt am 26 August das war vier Tage
vor der vollständigen Abschaltung von
nordstring danach nach der Stilllegung
und dann auch nach der Sprengung der
sind die Preise nicht nur nicht
gestiegen sondern sogar immer weiter
gefallen natürlich ist das Gas immer
immer noch extrem teuer es ist viel
teurer als vor einem oder vor zwei
Jahren aber die Tatsache dass die
Nachricht von Putins lieferstoffe das
Gaspreis nicht noch weiter in die Höhe
getrieben hat ist sehr aufschlussreich
und der Hauptgrund ist der folgen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Europäische Union erklärt im Sommer
sie wurde ihre Erdgasreserven bis zum 1
November auf 80% der Speicherkapazität
bringen nun dieses Ziel wurde bereits
Anfang September überschritten und
erreichte schließlich
98%. auch zur Zeitpunkt der Erstellung
dieses Videos also Anfang Dezember waren
die Deutschen Gasspeicher noch zu 98%
gefüllt das sind Seite 30% über dem
Niveau der Vorjahre mit anderen Worten
obwohl es kaum russisches Gas gibt hat
Europa genug Reserven und gut über den
Winter zu kommen und mit Hilfe von
energiespaßnahmen und weiteren Einkäufen
können diese Reserven sogar noch länger
gestreckt werden ja es wird kein
einfacher werden aber seid versichert es
wird wieder zu einem gasma geht um
kommen noch zur ölpokalypse also zu
Engpässen bei der Treibstoffversorgung
[Musik]
wir werden sogar einen Rückgang der
Preise beobachten können und am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
aus welchen Gründen Putin den
energiekrieg gegen Europa haushoch
verlieren wird und sollte es bei der
Stromversorgung in einzelnen Regionen
wie zum Beispiel Süddeutschland zu
Problemen oder gab Blackout kommen so
hat das nur indirekt was mit Putin zu
tun verantwortlich dafür ist vor allem
die ach so dringende Abschaltung der
dortigen Kernkraftwerke diese waren ja
akut Tsunami gefährdet nicht wahr Frau
Merkel aber eines nach dem anderen
fangen wir erstmal mit dem
grundlegendsten Fragen an woher bekommt
Europa all das Erdgas und das russische
Gas zu ersetzen wieso das Problem der
astronomischen Energiepreise bei
Gasstrom oder Sprit gelöst werden und
was noch wichtiger ist warum können wir
mit Funk und rechts sagen das ist
Russland viel schlechter geht als Putin
und seine Jünger behaupten warum schadet
der Energie kriegt Russland viel mehr
als Europa all diese Fragen werden wir
heute beantworten und zwar indem wir
zuerst einen kurzen Blick auf einige
wichtige wirtschaftliche Hintergründe
dürfen schnallt euch an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einer der größten Kritikpunkte am
Kapitalismus ist dass die Reichen immer
gewinnen richtig nun es gibt Zeiten in
denen das zutrifft und in einer solchen
befinden wir uns aber wisst ihr wer die
Reichen in dieser Geschichte sind ganz
genau die Europäische Union sprechen wir
es klar aus Europa hat Geld zumindest im
Vergleich zum großen Rest der Welt und
weil Europa reich ist hat es die ganze
Sache wie Elon Musk mit Twitter
durchgezogen mit einem Federstrich fast
den gesamten Gasmarkt übernommen wir
haben es im letzten Video zu diesem
Thema gesehen der Gasmarkt im Jahr 2022
sieht aus wie ein türkischer Basar wie
viel zahlt die Pakistan für diese
Schüssler Gas das ist mir egal ich zahle
dir mehr und das Fazit
die in dieser Grafik sehen könnt ist der
Gaspreis den ganzen Sommer über
gestiegen das lag daran dass Europa
bereit war ein Vermögen für all die
flüssiggastanker zu zahlen die ihre
Route zu den europäischen Häfen umleiten
würden dank all dieser Maßnahmen wurden
die Erdgasreserven direkt Kurzzeit
aufgefüllt Russland hin oder her all das
ist der wichtigste Rettungsanker der uns
über den Winter bringen wird aber nicht
nur das der Chart den wir eben
betrachtet haben und ihnen
wahrscheinlich schon in anderen Medien
gesehen habt das sind die Spot Preise
das heißt die Preise von gas-futures mit
sofortigem Verfall nun denn seht euch
noch diesen anderen Chart an
[Musik]
hier könnt ihr die langfristigen
gasfluters sehen wenn wir zum Beispiel
ein niederländisches gasfluter mit
Fälligkeit 2026 kaufen kostet es uns
deutlich weniger als vor dem Krieg das
bedeutet das Gas Investoren die in der
Regel wesentlich mehr Informationen
besitzen als der Durchschnittsbürger
erwarten dass die Gaspreise sinken
werden und warum fragt euch vielleicht
weil nach und nach neue Alternativen zum
russischen Gas auftauchen werden
Norwegen zum Beispiel fördert Gas in
Rekord Höhe aber der neue super
Gaslieferant sind los die US Open wir
haben bereits auf visualpolitik darüber
gesprochen Onkel ist ein exportiert mehr
Gas nach Europa als je zuvor aber ich
weiß was ihr denkt wenn ihr
visualpolitik schon länger verfolgt dann
wisst ihr bereits das passt das gesamte
Gas das nun von dem neuen Lieferanten
nach Europa gelangt nicht mit Platz
transportiert wird
[Musik]
es kommt als verflüssigtes Erdgas LNG
auf Tankern daher und dieses Gas hat ein
sehr großes Problem um LG zu beziehen
braucht ein Land spezielle energy
Terminals deren Herzstück auf gut wieder
verdampfungsanlage genannt wird denn LNG
ist bei der Förderung gewöhnliches
gasförmiges Erdgas das dann jedoch durch
Abkühlung auf unter 160 Grad minus in
eine Flüssigkeit umgewandelt wird diese
hat dann 600 Mal weniger Volumen es hat
Flüssiggas gut mit Spezialschiffen
transportiert werden kann aber sobald
Sie an Ihrem Zielort angekommen sind
müssen die verflüssigten
Kohlenwasserstoffe wie Methan Ethan
Butan wieder in Gas umgewandelt werden
und dafür sind sogenannte wieder
verdampfungsanlagen erforderlich nun
bisher gab es in Europa nur sehr wenige
solche Anlagen in Deutschland z.B gar
keine das Gas kann man über Pipelines
was feedbilliger war fast alle
europäischen wieder verdampfungsanlage
befanden sich in Spanien aber Spanien
ist bisher eine Art energieinsel da ist
kaum durch pipels mit dem was das
Kontinent verbunden ist sie unser Video
hierzu bislang war es vor allem
Frankreich dass die mit durch die
Pyrenäen blockiert hat nachdem die
Regulierungsbehörden bei der Länder die
kostspielige Infrastruktur 2019
abgelehnt hatten am 20 Oktober 2020 kam
jedoch endlich der Durchbruch Spanien
Frankreich Portugal schlossen ein
Übereinkommen zum Bau der Barmer
Pipeline die zuerst Erdgas späteren
Wasserstoff transportieren soll vor
allem Richtung Deutschland trotzdem hat
die Geschichte einen großen Haken die
französisch-spanische Barmer Pipeline
wird kurzfristig nur wenig zur Lösung
der Energiekrise beitragen während mit
Cut auf dem Landweg verlaufen sollte der
Barmer eine unterwasserpipeline sein
außerdem soll das Projekt zweite am
stärksten industrialisierten Städte im
Mittelmeerraum miteinander verbinden
eine unterwasserpipeline macht das ganze
Projekt komplizierter der Bau wird
länger dauern und teurer sein dies ist
eindeutig keine kurzfristige Lösung als
Ausblick aus der Krise sondern eine
langfristige Investition die Frage ist
also wie war es möglich dass Europa
plötzlich doch so schnell so viel
Energie in seine erdgas-punkten konnte
die Antwort liegt wieder einmal im
Kapitalismus weil Europa haben ist und
Geld auf den Schlägen kann entstehen
wunderlösung die vorher und denkbar
waren und ihr könnt mir glauben es wird
gerade eine Menge Geld auf dem Tisch
gelegt sieht selbst
[Musik]
das neue wirtschaftliche Wunderwerk sind
die schwimmenden Speicher und wieder
verdampfungsterminals von Fachleuten
nach der englischen Bezeichnung floating
storage an Register unit auch fsru
genannt oder umgangssprachlich LNG
Terminal Deutschland stellt 3 Milliarden
Euro für schwimmende lnt Terminals
bereit nun so ein schwimmendes Terminal
ist deutlich billiger als die Errichtung
einer neuen Anlage ein Land doch
einerseits kostet ein fsru zwischen 400
und 500 Millionen Dollar und
andererseits dauert der Bau eines
solchen Schiffes etwa 3 Jahre aber es
geht auch schneller und billiger wie
indem man mit Tante in schwimmenden
Terminals umwandelt das ist technisch
möglich oder vergleichsweise schneller
und schlechter Prozess da kann etwa 18
Monate dauern und zwischen 100 und 150
Millionen Dollar kosten und da ist sich
um schwimmende Terminals handelt können
Sie je nach Bedarf Inhalt weniger Monate
von einem Ort zum anderen verlegt werden
um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
es gibt derzeit 49 schwimmende Terminals
auf der Welt und 558 LG Tanker im Jahr
zum 21 gab es in Europa nur vier
schwimmende Terminals aber das ändert
sich nun rasant
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch das
Erdgas in bcms gemessen wird also in
Milliarden Kubikmeter nun zum Zeitpunkt
der Erstellung dieses Videos verfügen
die Niederlande bereits über zwei Stunde
Terminals die insgesamt 14 BCN
verarbeiten können und Tschechien das ja
ein Binnenland ist hat bereits
einen dieser Terminal unter Vertrag
genommen und Deutschland ist noch
beeindruckender zumindest was das völlig
undeutsche Tempo und den Eifer angeht
mit dem man in diesem Jahr auf den
verfassten Zug aufgesprungen ist
Deutschland hat sich 6 Stunde Anlagen
gesichert drei davon in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel und Lubin soll bis zum
Jahreswechsel betriebsbereit sein in LG
Beschleunigungsgesetz zum Dank und jetzt
lass uns eine kleine Rechnung aufstellen
ist es ja noch hatte Deutschland 45 bis
50 Milliarden Kubikmeter erdgast aus
Russland gekauft mit der wieder
verdampfungskapazität die bereits
vertraglich vereinbart wurde kann
Deutschland zwischen 40 und 45 bis sie
im Erdgas importieren
6 dezember 2022 Terminal in
Wilhelmshaven am Wochenende soll das
Spezialschiff eintreffen
die fsru ist das Herzstück des ersten
staatlich initiierten energy terminals
in Deutschland das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat es für
zehn Jahre geschafft hat und in seinem
Vertrag mit dem
besitzerifizierungsdauerleistung von 5
Milliarden Kubikmetern LNG pro Jahr
vereinbart maximal sind bis zu 7,5
Milliarden Kubikmeter LG pro Jahr
möglich sein Einsatz ist eine
Übergangslösung bis in einigen Jahren
voraussichtlich eingebautes an Land
seinen Betrieb aufnimmt insgesamt hat
Deutschland fünf FSA aus angemietet
wovon 2 in Wilhelmshaven eingesetzt
werden sollen neben dem Terminal von
Unicorn gibt es in der Jade statt ein
weiteres von DS das nach wenigen Jahren
auch schon zum Umschlagplatz für
Wasserstoff weiterentwickelt werden soll
mit anderen Worten Deutschland wird bis
zum nächsten Winter fast vollständig auf
russisches Gas verzichten können
zumindest was die empfangsinfrastruktur
angeht jetzt geht es also nur noch darum
ausreichend Lieferanten zu finden aber
wie bereits gesagt ist die gute
Nachricht für Europa das der alte
Kontinent Geld hat und bereit ist es in
neue Versorgungsinfrastruktur zu stecken
natürlich werden sich dadurch steigenden
Energiekosten auf die Wirtschaft
auswirken aber nicht so stark wie ein
vollständiges
außerdem können die Gaspreise falls sich
Europa geschickt anstatt langfristig
Widerstand sinken aber dazu später mehr
und ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken ja okay und was auch immer ihr
wollt aber wer bezahlt meine ihre
Stromrechnung und die Heizkosten ich
komme doch jetzt schon nicht über die
Runden gibt es eine Lösung für dieses
Problem nun genau das werden wir jetzt
unter die Lupe nehmen
verhindert
Europa als Ganzes ist relativ reich und
hat Geld mobilisiert um für das Gas zu
bezahlen aber nicht alle Europäer sind
reich genug um ihre teuflisch hohen
Strom und Gasrechnungen zu bezahlen und
hier kommt eine interessante Frage ins
Spiel Tschechien ist eines der Länder in
denen der Strompreis am stärksten
gestiegen ist allerdings haben die
Tschechien Atomkraftwerke die 80% ihres
Stromnetzes ausmachen und ist Atomkraft
nicht eigentlich eine billige
Energiequelle wie ist es möglich dass
diese Tatsache ihre Stromrechnungen
nicht senkt nun hier kommt unser Freund
das grenzpreissystem ist spielt das
heißt der Preis an der Strombörse wird
von der jeweils teuersten Quelle
bestimmt und zu diesem Preis müssen die
stromversorge all jene Kapazitäten von
Atomkraftwerken solarfarmen
Gaskraftwerken zwischen Händlern und so
weiter einkaufen welche sie sich nicht
zuvor über Verträge gesichert haben
jeden Tag wird eine Auktion durchgeführt
um den gesamten Strombedarf des Tages zu
decken nehmen wir zum Beispiel an das
Deutschland heute voraussichtlich 1,5
Terawattstunden energieverbrauchen wird
die Auktion beginnt und die billigsten
Quellen wie die Atomkraft kommen diesem
Zug vergesst nicht das Atomkraftwerke
und unterbrochenen Betrieb sind nicht so
einfach ihre Leistung Regeln können also
werden sie unabhängig vom Preis Energie
liefern sie werden ihren Strom auch für
0 Euro verkaufen egal was passiert dann
kommen grüne Energien die teurer sind
dann Kohle Wasserkraft und so weiter und
schließlich kommen wir zum Gas
[Musik]
da der Gaspreis in die Höhe geschossen
ist können die Gaskraftwerke nicht unter
eine bestimmten Betrag verkaufen und Sie
müssen es auch nicht da sie ihre
Leistung sehr einfach hoch und
runterfahren können sie nehmen also
sagen wir mal 190 € pro megabadstunde
dann wäre der preisstunde Strom an
diesem Tag eben jene 190 €. das ist das
grenzpreis-system und es hat Jahre lang
sehr gut funktioniert allerdings wurde
es nicht für Kriegsbedingungen
entwickelt was passiert also jetzt nun
die klassischen energieerzeuge Atomkraft
Ökostrom und so weitermachen
außerordentliche Gewinne und wer kommt
für diese externen Gewinne auf wer sind
die großen verliere ganz genau die
verbrauche und jede Energieunternehmen
die Gas auf dem internationalen Markt
kaufen müssen überlegt mal wenn ein
Stromversorger gezwungen ist seine Strom
zum Grenzpreis einzukaufen zahlt das
Unternehmen horrende Preise trotzdem
zahlen in vielen Fällen Verbraucher
Pauschalreise verstorben es gibt also
nicht nur verbrauche die nicht über die
Runden kommen sondern auch viele
energieversorge ein ganz Europa die sind
ihre Leistungen stark kürzen oder sogar
am Rande des trotz stehen das gilt
übrigens auch für Gasversorger und
erklärter Nachrichten wie diese
Deutschlands größter Gast Importeur
bittet um Staatshilfe uniper-aktie
Bericht ein so weit so schlecht aber wie
könnte das alles gelöst werden
nun die Debatte ist immer noch im Gange
einige Länder wollen in das Preissystem
Eingreifen anstatt die Preise per
Auktion festzulegen würden sie vom Staat
bestimmt das würde jedoch den
Energiemarkt durcheinander werfen und
die Rechtssicherheit untergraben
langfristig würde es nicht als Probleme
schaffen deswegen konnte sich eine
solche Deckelung der Gaspreise Inhalte
und nicht durchsetzen welche andere
Lösung kann dann aber angewendet werden
ganz einfach diejenigen die am meisten
haben sollten auch am meisten zahlen und
wer ist das ganz genau die
Energieerzeugung es geht um eine Steuer
auf die außerordentlichen Gewinner die
die Besitzer von Atomkraftwerken im
Windparks und so weiter aufgrund der
exorten Preise gegenwärtig erzielen die
EU-Staaten haben hierzu eine gemeinsame
Vereinbarung getroffen und einige wie
Italien Rumänien und Spanien sowie
Großbritannien haben solche sogenannten
über Gewinnsteuern bereits eingeführt in
Deutschland sind sie ebenfalls
beschlossen sie soll für zwei Dinge
verwendet werden mögliche
Rettungsaktionen für Stromunternehmen
und Subventionen für die Verbraucher die
in den Stromrechnungen ertrinken andere
Länder ergreifen zu weiteren ebenfalls
drastischen Lösungen um weitere
Verzerrungen zu vermeiden Resultat sind
dann solche Schlagzeilen Deutschland
beschlagte Raffinerien des russischen
Ölkonzerns rasnewt das Fazit die
Situation ändert sich von Tag zu Tag
aber es gibt viel Möglichkeiten das Gas
magadon zu vermeiden ja es wird in
diesem Winter zu einigen Einschränkungen
im Rahmen von Sparmaßnahmen kommen
ab Dezember soll zu Spitzenzeiten Strom
gespart werden so die Forderung der
Europäischen Kommission um die
Energiesicherheit zu erhöhen soll die
Mitgliedstaaten also Energie sparen Ende
September hat die Kommission sie dazu
verpflichtet den Verbrauch in den
Spitzenzeiten zu senken wenn die Last am
höchsten ist das Ziel ist es in diesen
Zeiträumen Einsparung von mindestens
fünf Prozent zu erzielen die Maßnahmen
und die Wahl der Zeitpunkte zu den
Energieeinsparungen vorgenommen werden
sollen sind aber den einzelnen Ländern
überlassen die Regierungen mussten ihre
Sparpläne bis Ende November bei der
Europäischen Kommission einreichen sie
wollen diese vor allem durch freiwillige
sparende Verbraucher erreichen
Einsparungen aber auch durch den
Einstieg der Energiepreise zu
Spitzenzeiten erzielen außerdem gibt es
in einzelnen Staaten Mechanismen auf
Grundlage der preisdeckung zum Beispiel
Strompreis für einige Unternehmen nicht
für den gesamten Verbrauch gewechselt
sondern nur für 80% des Verbrauchs Ziel
der Maßnahmen ist es den Einsatz von
Gaskraftwerken zu minimieren die zu
Zeiten der Spitzen Nachfrage zu Einsatz
kommen und deren hohe Kosten den
Strompreis auch ein bisher nicht
gekanntes Niveau treiben es wird zu
Reduzierung der Beleuchtung von Städten
und Gebäuden kommen und auch die
Heiztemperatur in öffentlichen Gebäuden
wird ein wenig gesägt Unternehmen werden
Schwierigkeiten haben energieintensive
Produktionsprozesse wirtschaftlich
betreiben zu können und für alle werden
saftige Rechnungen bezahlen müssen aber
es wird Gas im Winter geben und es gibt
Geld um Hilfe zu leisten um soziale
Probleme zu vermeiden das Erreichen der
geforderten Verbrauchsreduzierung wird
mittlerweile nicht mehr als großes
Problem angesehen also Stromverbrauch
seit Anfang des Jahres rückläufig ist
und obwohl die Einsparungen nicht ganz
so groß sind die bei Gas in der
Verbrauch mit den Beginn der Heizung und
der Abkühlung november ebenfalls
gestiegen ist wird es nicht so schwierig
sein dass europäische Ziel zu erreichen
aber lasst uns doch unser anfangs
erwähntes Beispiel Tschechien noch mal
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei den 70.000 demonstratten in Prag
handelt es sich natürlich nicht
ausschließlich um Putin Fans die meisten
waren einfach nur sauer auf ihre
Regierung sie würde nichts gegen die auf
sie zukommenden horrenten und auf
Existenz betonen Rechnungen für Strom
und Gasunternehmen ihre Sorgen waren
durchaus berechtigt denn das Land war
noch weitaus stärker von russischen Gas
abhängig als Deutschland gerade zu 100%,
die größte Schwierigkeit bestand dabei
darin eine regelmäßige Gaszufuhr über
die ins Land führenden Pipelines zu
sichern denn diese entspricht im Grunde
genommen etwa der Entladung von sieben
LG Tankern pro Monat am von den
Tschechien angemieteten holländischen
Terminal die nächste Herausforderung
besteht darin dass Mitteleuropa nächste
Mitte ganz ohne russisches Gas auskommen
muss das könnte vielleicht schwieriger
werden als in diesem Jahr denn jetzt
gibt es doch reservice die teilweise mit
russischen Gas gefüllt wurden dass das
Herbst über nordstrigen geflossen ist
wenn Deutschland innerhalb eines Jahres
sechs LNG Terminals baut kann die
Energiekrise in Mitteleuropa auch
mittelfristig abgewendet werden und
obwohl das LG wahrscheinlich teurer sein
wird als das russische Pipeline Gas
könnte das gemeinsame europäische
gasbezugsabkommen über das die Union
derzeit verhandelt die Kosten wieder
senken sobald sich die neue
gasinfrastruktur nämlich eingespielt
hatte wird das Preisniveau automatisch
denken wenn die hohen Ausschläge beruhen
eben auf den Verwerfungen der rasanten
Übergangsphase weg vom russischen Gas
viele Experten gehen daher davon aus
dass der Gaspreis in Europa innerhalb
von 10 Monaten auf ein Niveau fallen
wird das im Schnitt nur 10% über den
ursprünglichen Gaspreisen vor der Krise
liegen wird allerdings darf man nicht
außer Acht lassen dass ich die derzeit
hören Preise noch eine ganze Weile in
den anbieterpreisen niederschlagen
werden zu Beginn des Jahres wurde Gas in
Europa für rund 35 € pro Megawattstunde
gehandelt und schon jetzt ist anhand der
Future Preise zu denen die großen
Gasversorger meist ihre Lieferungen
absichern zu erkennen dass er
langfristig bei 40 Euro herauskommen
werden sobald sich all der Trubel gelegt
hat und zwar ganz ohne Gas aus Russland
[Musik]
fakt ist nämlich dass jene Experten die
am Anfang der Krise besonders laut
geschrien haben das ohne gasausland
alles zusammenbrechen würde meist selbst
wirtschaftlich stark vom Gasgeschäft mit
Russland abhängig sind und daher nicht
ganz unvoreingenommen waren und damit
wären wir auch schon am anderen Ende der
gegenwärtigen Probleme und Entwicklungen
und zwar deren Auswirkungen auf Russland
erinnert ihr euch noch an die Moskauer
Sonne jedes Riesenrad das Putin im Herz
in Moskau eingeweiht hat fun fact am
Rande einen Tag nach seiner Eröffnung
wurde es wegen technischer Probleme erst
einmal wieder abgeschaltet nun
mittlerweile dreht es sich wieder
dennoch war diese Panne ziemlich
symbolisch für das was gegenwärtig in
Russland passiert behaltet zwei Dinge im
Hinterkopf erstens das Gas und Öl das
Russland nach Europa verkauft hat machte
45 % einer gesamten Exporte aus mit
anderen Worten das Loch das jetzt in
Russland staatsgasse entsteht ist
genauso groß wie die Stromrechnungen die
die Europäer bezahlen zweitens die
Kosten des Krieges weil die frontötet
war der Kreml Personen eine Mobilmachung
durchzuführen mindestens 300.000 junge
und nicht ganz so junge Männer wurden
eingezogen und werden zum Teil bereits
an der Front verheizt hunderttausende
wenn ich kann Millionen weitere Russen
haben sich aus Angst vor ihrer
Einziehung ins Ausland abgesetzt oder
wenigstens auf die Dacia oder zu Oma
aufs Dorf wo sie für die Häscher des
regins nicht auffindbar sind die
immobilienmachung verursachte den Kreml
also nicht nur zusätzliche enorme Kosten
für sold Waffen und Ausrüstung dieser
Männer sondern ist auch ein eklatanter
wirtschaftlicher Schlag denn all diese
Leute fehlen nur der russischen
Volkswirtschaft sowohl als Arbeitskräfte
wie auch als Konsumenten und ihre
Familien sind zutiefst verunsichert was
ihnen die Zukunft bringen wird laut
einer vom Kreml in Auftrag gegebene
Meinungsumfrage nur für den internen
gebraucht die dann doch irgendwie nach
außen gelegt wurde sind mittlerweile 55
% der Russen dafür dass Russland auf
diplomatischen Wege Frieden mit der
Ukraine schließt nur noch eine Viertel
der Befragten unterstützt den Krieg
den Vergleich mit der vorhergehenden
Umfrage aus derselben Quelle ist die
Unterstützung für den Krieg nun also um
25 Prozentpunkte gesunken laut Angaben
des levadazentrums eine russische nicht
Regierungsorganisation hängt der
Meinungswandel der Russen nicht nur mit
den Niederlagen und der Front zusammen
sein und vor allem mit der Mobilisierung
erst nach ihrer Ausrufung kann sich die
russische Bevölkerung ernsthaft für
Friedensgespräche zu interessieren denn
die meisten leben es trotz patriotischer
Töne völlig ab sich persönlich ankriegt
zu beteiligen die anfänglich starke
Unterstützung des Krieges innerhalb der
Bevölkerung lag an der Tatsache dass sie
es als etwas ansahen dass sie nicht
selbst betrachten sondern von Putin und
seinen Profis für sie erledigt würde
aber jetzt bekommen ist die Russen
wirklich mit der Angst zu tun weil sie
wissen dass das Risiko steigt seine
eigene Haut für die süßen Großmacht
Träume rein hinhalten zu müssen drittens
die Sanktionen die Förderung von Kohle
Öl und Gas ist rückläufig viele Fabriken
im Land stehen still oder Arbeiten auf
Sparflamme weil es ihnen ein
unabdingbaren Materialien oder
Komponenten fehlt dass die russische
Wirtschaft gerade bei steil abschmiert
bestätigt inzwischen sogar die
offizielle Statistik der Regierung das
BIP Russland ist im September um 5%
gegenüber September 2021 zurückgegangen
für das dritte Quartal liegt der Wert
bei -4,4% gegenüber dem Vorjahr so das
Ministerium für Wirtschaft und
Entwicklung in diesen Zahl ist übrigens
der mobilnachungsschock den die
russische Gesellschaft eine September
erlebt eigentlich noch gar nicht
abgebildet und viertens alte Freunde
wenden sich ab Pfötchen hat sich im Herz
mit getroffen und auch Unterstützung aus
China gehofft die aber nicht kommt china
steht im Ukraine kriegt weiterhin
neutral und hilft Russland auch nicht
groß mit sanktionsgütern aus beim Besuch
des deutschen Bundeskanzlers Olaf schoss
in Peking destinierte sich die Wikinger
führen sogar ungewöhnlich deutlich vom
russischen Angriffskriegen
Regierungschefin zusammen mit
Deutschland auf einem baldiges Ende des
Kriegs in der Ukraine wir können uns
keine weitere Eskalation leisten es sei
nun an der Zeit beide Seiten
zufriedensgespräch zu bewegen sagte die
wir wollen nicht dass die regionale
Stabilität erschüttert wird das
internationale Produktions-
wollen wir nicht Regierungschef Lee
sagte er hoffe zusammen mit Deutschland
auf ein baldiges Ende des Krieges in der
Ukraine nun war in den letzten Wochen
jedoch eine Menge frachtflugverkehr
zwischen Moskau und jengauer einem
wichtigen Transport und Logistikzentrum
in China registriert worden die
Maschinen hatten zudem ihre Transponder
ausgeschaltet
[Musik]
ukrainische Nachrichtenagentur die Fans
Express konnte die Flugzeuge trotzdem
auf diese Weise berechnen das auf den
geheimflugen bis zu 1.500 Tonnen Güter
nach Russland hätten geschafft werden
können nun mag das noch viele klingen
aber wenn es um militärische Ausrüstung
geht sind 1500 Tonnen nicht besonders
viel sollte er sich bei den Gütern z.B
im Winterausrüstung handelt so könnten
damit höchstens 15 bis 20.000 Mann
versorgt werden es kann sich also
höchstens um einen Notnagel handeln um
die größten Lücken zu stopfen aber der
Kreml ist ja auch schon super Zweifel
dass er Munition und Waffen im Iran und
Nordkorea einkaufen muss mit anderen
Worten Pokerface Putin steckt zunehmend
in Schwierigkeiten er hat im Westen
nicht nur seine Beruf sondern auch seine
Haupteinnahmequelle und seinen
Hauptlieferanten für Komponenten
verloren putin wird zwar nicht müde
Gebets mühlenartig zu wiederholen dass
der wirtschaftliche Blitzkrieg des
Westens gescheitert sei in Wahrheit ist
er jedoch extrem besorgt dass ich
Sanktion nicht nur die Fähigkeiten
Russlands beeinträchtigt haben Waren zu
produzieren auch den Mangel an
Militärausrüstung verschärfen und die
Möglichkeiten des Landes einschränken
eine neue Bodenoffensive zu starten oder
neue Raketen zu bauen selbst die
russische Presse weist auf große
Probleme bei der Versorgung der neu
eingezogenen wertwichtigen mit
Ausrüstung kennen ein ausführlicher
Bericht in der russischen Zeitung
commerzan vom Oktober sprach von einem
enormen Mangel an Munition und Uniformen
für die Wehrpflichtigen da die
Hersteller aufgrund der
sanktionsschwierigkeiten hätten das
notwendige Material zu beschaffen
deswegen Bericht Putin einen neuen
Wirtschaftsrat ein er die Probleme
irgendwie in den Griff bekommen soll und
auch alle objektiven Indikatoren zeigen
eindeutig dass sich die Sanktion immer
stärker in die russische Wirtschaft
einfräsen und es zu einem immer
stärkeren Rücken der wirtschaftlichen
Aktivität kommt diese Abwärtsspirale
dreht sich immer schneller und es gibt
keinen Ausweg mehr
[Musik]
die offiziellen Zahlen des russischen
Finanzministeriums verraten und zum
Beispiel dass die Steuereinnahmen aus
allen Sektoren der Wirtschaft außer Öl
und Gas im Oktober im Vergleich zum
vorher um 20% eingebrochen sind
miserable Zahlen veröffentlichte auch
die staatliche russische
Statistikbehörde Rostock die meldete
dass die Einzelhandelsumsätze im
September im Vergleich zum vorher um 10%
oder Umsatz in Güterverkehr und 7%
gesunken sind wohlgemerkt von einem
Niveau aus das bereits durch Corona
niedergebügelt worden war der
Internationale Währungsfonds hat für
dieses Jahr zwar nur einen Rückgang des
russischen BIP von 3,5% prognostiziert
also viel weniger als ursprünglich
angenommen aber sowohl Ökonomen als auch
Unternehmer Berichten aus der Praxis
dass die die bezahlen nicht die wahren
Zustand der russischen Wirtschaft
widerspiegeln der Hauptgrund dafür ist
dass der kremme die Konvertierbarkeit
des Rubels nach der verhindern dass
Aktion praktisch beendet hat diese
extrem kostspielige Manipulation schön
die IP Zahlen erheblichen Ausmaß für
jedoch zu einer Blasenbildung die den
großen später umso stärker um die Ohren
fliegen wird bzw er implodiert das
Militär Debakel Russlands in der Ukraine
hat denn auch enorme Ineffizienzen und
Korruption immer russischen
militärischen industriellen Komplex
aufgedeckt immer mehr außen stellen sich
die Frage wo denn all die Billionen
Rubel geblieben sind die im letzten
Jahrzehnt für die Modernisierung der
Armee ausgegeben worden waren nun
darüber haben wir schon mehrere Videos
gedreht vor der Invasion und auch danach
[Musik]
mehrere Form ein mindestens ebenso
großer Flop war wie sein Gas Joker mit
dem Europa erpressen wollte zwar sind
ironischerweise die Importe russischen
lngs nach Europa gestiegen jedoch nicht
mal auf ein Zehntel dessen was Russland
früher über Pipelines in den besten
gepumpt hat zudem begann wie gesagt am 5
dezember 2020 eine weitere große
Bewährungsprobe für die Fähigkeiten des
Westens Russland wirklich so Schaden das
verboten russische Öle Importe in die EU
mit Krankheit und die von der G7
vereinbarte Preisobergrenze für
russisches Öl weltweit
G7 einigt sich auf Ölpreis Obergrenze
russlandseinnahmen reduzieren und
gleichzeitig die globalen Energiemärkte
stabil halten während das EU
Importverbot für russisches Zeugnisse
auf dem Seeweg in vollem Umfang bestehen
bleibt erlaubt die Preis Obergrenze
europäischen Unternehmen russisches Öl
in Drittländer zu transportieren sofern
der Preis strikt unter der Obergrenze
bleibt übrigens darf über die
berufspapier noch bis 2024 russisches Öl
nach Europa fließen dann ist auch damit
Schluss allerdings hat Polen angekündigt
das ist seinen Teil der Pipeline
abschalten wird davon ist auch
Deutschland betroffen die Raffinerien in
Schwick und Leuna können nicht
vollständig über den Hafen Rostock
versorgt werden und es gibt keine
Verbindungen nach Westdeutschland aber
warum ist das Öl im varo überhaupt
derart nun die Förderung oder Export von
Erdöl und Erdölprodukten machen etwa 20
bis 30% des BIP Russlands aus und sind
mit etwa 70% die hauptwiesen Quelle des
Gremlin schon vor Jahren sagte
US-Senator John mcca mal Russland ist
eine Tankstelle die von einer Mafia
betrieben wird die sich als Staat
ausgibt
und siehe da die pressobergrenze der G7
hat bereits kurz nach ihrem
Inkrafttreten katastrophale Auswirkungen
für Russland
russische rohölexporte auf dem Seeweg
brechen in den ersten Tagen des Verbots
ein die Entscheidung der Türkei den
Versicherungsstatus von Tankern zu
überprüfen die durch ihre Gewässer
fahren hält eine wachsende Zahl von
Schiffen auf nach Angaben von
tinkertrackers.com verließen am Montag
und Dienstag insgesamt nur 3,88
Millionen Russland perseweg das ist ein
Rückgang von fast 50% gegenüber dem
normalen Niveau wobei die größten
Rückgänge in den Regionen Ostsee und
Schwarzes Meer zu verzeichnen waren die
Frage lautet also warum wird der Westen
dieses Sanktion die Russland ja wirklich
weh tun erst jetzt nach 9 Monaten Krieg
nur die Antwort ist so einfach wie
pragmatisch der besten will Russland
schaden damit es mit seinen Aggressionen
aufhört aber es macht keinen Sinn sich
etwas vor zu machen ich Sanktion Schaden
den besten ebenfalls daher war es
wichtig eine Balance zu finden diesen
Schaden bei sich zu minimieren in den
Lieferketten entsprechend umgestellt und
angepasst werden und das kann eine Weile
dauern wie wir in ein Video über
Raffinerie Interesse auf unserem
Schwester Kanal visualkonomica gelegt
haben besteht das Problem darin dass
nicht jede Raffinerie Ölsorte
verarbeiten kann und viele Raffinerien
waren eben auf russisches Öl
ausgerichtet deswegen war das nun in
Kraft getriebene Verbote Einfuhr von
russischen Ölprodukten so schwer
umzusetzen zum Beispiel wurde diesen
hauptsächlich von Westeuropa importiert
und zwar eine Milliarde Liter pro Monat
ein sofortiger
import-chaos verursacht in der
Zwischenzeit wurde jedoch dafür gesorgt
dass dies nicht passiert der Markt ist
sogar dermaßen über versorgt dass selbst
mit dem Verbot die Preise für Benzin und
Diesel an den Tankstellen nicht steigen
werden im Gegenteil
[Musik]
ein ähnliches Konzept steckt hinter dem
Preis Deckel der G7 es geht nicht um ein
vollständiges russisches Öl Russland ist
ein wichtiger Exporteur und kann ich
vollständig vom Welthandel
ausgeschlossen werden was man aber
machen kann ist die Einnahme des
russischen Staates aus dem Export
deutlich zu stutzen tatsächlich ist dies
zu einem Teil bereits seit Februar 2022
der Fall als westliche
Versicherungsgesellschaften die
Versicherung für russische Kranke
einstellten danach verboten die USA und
normalerweise Import der russischen
Erdöls jetzt kommt das EU Importverbot
und das Verbot hinzu Tanker von
westlichen Rädern zu scheitern Russland
ist deswegen bereits seit geraumer Zeit
gezwungen Öl unter großen Preis
Nachlässen von etwa 30 Dollar pro Barrel
zu verkaufen eine Reihe von Ländern
China Indien die Türkei und so weiter
profitiert davon und ihre
Verhandlungsposition gegenüber Russland
wird sich jetzt noch weiter verbessern
tja weder Modi noch Ski noch Erdogan
sind zentimentale Menschen oder
Wohltäter russland versucht natürlich
mit allen Mitteln sich gegen die
preisdruckerei zurückzusetzen vor allem
in dem es ältere kranke aufkauft in
diesem Jahr haben die großen über 100
Schiffe gekauft darunter 29 wie lcces
sogenannte very large krutcher das sind
die größten Tanker aller Zeiten mit
einer Kapazitäten über 2 Millionen
russland baut eine schattenflotte von
Tank an auf um die Ölsanktionen zu
umgehen Russland noch mehr Tanker als
bisher benötigen weil jede Fahrt länger
dauert Öl das bisher innerhalb Europas
verkauft wurde wird er neue Abnehmer in
Asien geschickt Russland bräuchte mehr
als 240 Tanker um seine derzeitigen
Exporte mehr zu erhalten man kann sich
alle möglichen cleveren Pläne ausdenken
aber es muss einfach zu viel Öl
transportiert werden sie werden immer
Schwierigkeiten haben in dem Umfang zu
operieren der notwendig ist um die
russischen Exporte ohne Preisobergrenzen
aufrecht zu halten
in den kommenden Wochen werden wir also
sehen welchen Einfluss der Westen in der
heutigen Welt wirklich haben klar ist
die Globalisierung wie wir sie kannten
ist vorbei und mit ihr viele Vorzüge die
wir so lieb gewonnen hatten Zufall
gebracht wurde sie durch Männer wie
Putin und was an ihre Stelle treten wird
ist unmöglich vorher zu sehen was wir
doch können ist nachdenken Nachdenken
über mögliche Szenarien und die
Wahrscheinlichkeit mit der diese
eintreten könnten so wie wir es hier
offizielle Politik schon lange vor den
24 Februar getan haben vergessen also
bitte nicht falls ihr das nicht schon
getan habt das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um keinen unserer
Gedankengänge zu verpassen und diesmal
vielleicht besser vorbereitet zu sein
aber jetzt seid erstmal ihr mit euren
Gedanken an der Reihe denkt ihr dass die
russischen Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen
wird glaubt ihr dass diese Maßnahmen
ausreichend werden damit Europa in
diesem Winter keinen Gaston und keine
ölpalypse erlebt oder werden wir
vielleicht bei Gas und Benzinpreisen
neue Höhen erleben wie immer sind auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gebt
uns bitte ein Like da sind und Freunden
und vergesst wie gesagt nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen und keines unserer Videos
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video mach's
gut bis bald
[Musik]